[Music]
okay
hey ninjas it's me nia and it's back to
school time
so i'm gonna show you everything you
need in your locker to be ninja and
nail the school year anyone can be ninja
if you feel strong
confident and here's the ninja's guide
to everything a ninja needs
to be a ninja first i'd like to have
photos of all my heroes who inspire me
next you need a ninja mask to protect
your secret identity
nobody knows mine except for kai called
jay zane lloyd
and you because we're butts i've also
got sushi for lunch
my lucky chopsticks oh and here's
something every ninja needs in her
locker
makeup to camouflage for stealth
missions
[Music]
see perfectly camouflaged so ninja
garmadon run run looks like i gotta go
take care of this
so if you do happen to be a real ninja
the last thing your locker needs
a secret passageway leading to a
warehouse space filled with butt kicking
mechs
have a great school year
the lego ninjago movie ready pg
[Music]
you ready for me to conquer ninjago oh
i'll be waiting
dad
sorry what was that last thing you said
what
that last one i didn't catch it well i i
didn't say anything what do you mean i
didn't
i said i'll be waiting and then i
stopped talking
dad the lloyd that's right
your son and it's lloyd no
lloyd i named you you've ruined my life
that's not true i haven't even been a
part of your life how could i ruin it i
wasn't even there
baby now
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm taking a solomon to form the secret
ninja force are you ready to risk your
life
for ninjago yes i am on it
maybe
garmadon
stuck i know you want me to save myself
so i'll go now
i promise i'll never forget you i didn't
ask you to promise that
come back
hello who is this lloyd garmadon your
son
hmm
[Music]
it's okay lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect i mean my mom
is weird and collects seashells your dad
level cities and attacks innocent people
so they've all got their quirks you know
[Music]
bye